you know Snoopy and Rudolph and Garfield
and the Grinch and the Christmas
episodes of your favorite shows in a
pinch but do you
recall the most unusual and possibly
Forgotten Christmas specials of the
[Music]
mall hey there folks it's almost
Christmas and actually if I was better
at scheduling I might have put this out
a little bit earlier because this is
coming out a couple days before
Christmas there's a good chance you're
already doing all sorts of family stuff
and by the time you get to this
Christmas will have happened and you'll
be sick of hearing about it you won't
watch this I should have put this out
earlier in the month I don't plan well
to be fair this is replacing something
that I had intended to do but had a
logistics problem and that's now getting
bumped to who knows when but anyways
welcome to the rambling nonsense that is
my channel and my brain uh I want to
talk about Christmas specials but not
the ones you know now I'm not
necessarily going to claim that these
are the weirdest or these most the most
obscure but these are ones I definitely
don't see people talking about and a lot
of these are ones I hadn't seen myself
before this year I got brought in and
introduced to a whole bunch of stuff I
had seen before and it's worth checking
out cuz there's all the stand
there's the stuff you know and love
there's some stuff out there you might
not know
about I'd say give it a shot so I'm
going to go through five examples of
Christmas specials that seem to have
been forgotten or were missed in the
first place or are just a little bit off
the beaten path I'm going to tell you a
little bit about them and what I thought
about them let's start with something
adjacent to stuff you know because Rank
and bass Christmas specials everybody
knows those Rudolph The Year Without a
Santa Claus where that cold meiser heat
meiser song comes from heck even the 2D
handrawn TW was the night before
Christmas with the mice not as well-
beloved I love that one but not as well
beloved but a lot of people go like all
right I remember that how many of you
saw the Life and Adventures of Santa
Claus that
one that one's a trip and if you've
actually rewatched some of the stuff
like Rudolph even that stuff was kind of
of a trip but by that even by that
metric this is this is something else so
a couple things about this this is done
in the 80s so it's actually way more
refined stop motion animation and flatly
looks better than Rank and bass is much
more famous and wellknown and beloved
stop motion animation things like
Rudolph the Red-nose Reindeer this looks
quite good the motion is way smoother
the mouths especially work so much
better than I'm used to seeing from
aning bass now you might just think it's
okay so it's just Santa Claus story
right well it is so it's based off a
Frank Al bound book the original author
of The Oz books rard of Oz
and all the ones that came after
that and if you've actually ever read
any Frank albam especially if you've
read any of his later odd stuff or like
his non o related material you'll know
the
guy the guy he went places pulled weird
stuff and acted like it was the most
nonchalant thing on the world and that's
very much on display here this is based
off one of his stories and the short
version and I'm not going to go beat for
beat cuz I still want you to have a
reason to watch it I don't want to spoil
anything but it's basically Santa Claus
as raised by Woodland spirits and
fairies that's his origin he was raised
by the
Fay and it gets weirder for from there
but if you like the rank and bass stuff
or you have any Nostalgia for it at all
this will tickle that Nostalgia cuz it's
going to look like a refined version of
stuff you already love but it's also
going to give you something a little
weirder a little more unusual and
honestly just fun next up one that I oh
boy I don't even really know how to
explain this one it's called Cosmic
Christmas and
it's it's about some aliens that land on
Earth and a young boy who tries to
explain to them the concept of Christmas
and some people in the area are kind of
freaking out about the aliens some
people are not and it's the looking at
Christmas through Outsider eyes thing
that you might get a little bit of from
something like Nightmare Before
Christmas mhm if you didn't notice these
earrings I feel like they're worth
highlighting you know there's that
aspect but also like the boy realizing
he he's having a hard time finding
something that he can show them that
actually truly embodies the spirit of
Christmas as he as a small child
understands it he keeps trying these
different things but it's not quite
showing them what he feels when
Christmas comes it's really sweet and it
is just slightly weird honestly the tone
of it it feels a fair bit like something
that well something this wholesome
wouldn't have been but if you've ever
seen the movie Heavy Metal or read the
Magazine heavy metal its tone feels like
a wholesome uh version of something that
would have appeared in The Heavy Metal
movie the style of Animation the feel of
the performances and just the general
overall mood of the thing kind of fits
in that we're just here to experience
this bit of weirdness right now come
with us if you want like I said
comparing it to heavy metal might be a
mistake on my part because tonally it is
not that at all but there's just some
something about the feel of it it very
much gave me that overall uh sense of
things and if you like that sort of
thing and you want something that feels
a little bit like that that is safe to
actually expose the kids to give Cosmic
Christmas a try now the next one if you
are from my generation or were watching
children targeted entertainment in
the80s you might know this one but it
seems to have largely been lost at time
if you didn't catch it at the time it
came out and that is Will Von's
clamation Christmas now if you don't
know the name Will Vinton he made a name
for himself doing a clamation work most
famously the California Raisins who yes
naturally do make an appearance uh in
this as do some uh Creations for some of
his earlier stuff I actually know will
vinton's clation best from a dinosaurs
sort of special that he participated in
and he reused some of those models for
this what I like about this one in
addition to assuming that his style of
clamation doesn't put you you off cuz I
have talked to some people who find it
uncanny and unsettling and if that is
the case feel free to skip it but if
that's not the case for you what's nice
about this is it doesn't try and tell a
story not that it's a problem for ones
that do but it's really more than
anything just giving fun little
clamation music videos for a number of
Christmas carols we get things like the
Carol of the Bells we get things like We
Three Kings Rudolph the rednose reindeer
and it's it is largely just giving us
these songs as performed quote unquote
by these clation characters but it it
just gives it that unique sense and feel
that Will Vinton brought to his style of
clamation and if you either have a love
of stop motion animation and you aren't
familiar with will vitton this is pretty
short it might be a good introduction to
his work or if you are familiar with his
work but you haven't seen this give it a
look or in my case if you actually start
watching it and realize oh crap I have
seen this before like over 30 years ago
look it up next I want to talk about 12
tiny Christmas Tales by of all people
Bill
Plimpton so it's hard to know what
people know Bill Plimpton from if you
know him at all I actually think there's
a pretty good chance that a lot of
people especially younger than me these
days would know him from a number of
Simpsons couch gags that he did in his
signature sort of squiggle animation
style but he's been doing shorts and
features for ages most famously ones
like your face and guard dog also been
hired like just for a lot of commercials
and stuff throughout the 80s 90s early
2000s even this was a special that he
did for Cartoon Network now I say Bill
Plimpton and Cartoon Network if you're
familiar with a lot of Bill plimpton's
work you might you might immediately
think oh this is an adult swim thing
isn't it because Bill
Plimpton you dig into his work
at the man has a very distinct sense of
humor um but funnily enough this came
out a couple years before Adult Swim was
the thing so this is wholesome Bill
Plimpton so this is still his signature
look animation style the still
occasional bit of absolute anarchic
chaos going on but it is largely
wholesome it is a grandmother sharing 12
different I believe original I didn't
recognize any of them short Christmas
stories all sweet all appropriate for
kids and just told with his visual
stylings which is unmistakable and
Incredibly unique so while I kind of
went into this because I know the man's
work expecting something a little more
chaotic than what I got It's actually
kind of nice to see the style from an
artist who I know can get very not safe
for work and very off thewall in a way
that I actually generally enjoy just see
him bring it back just a little bit and
still have that same core but package it
in a familyfriendly way some might think
of something like that as selling out
but I'm like no that's still definitely
Bill Plimpton he toned himself down a
little bit for this and it's actually
kind of sweet before I get to the one
that I want to recommend the most
emphatically um I'm going to make a uh
note for kind of an honorable mention
I'm going to bring up Christmas and
tatter town which is done by Ralph Baki
now I'm not going to give this one a
blanket recommendation cuz it's very
Ralph Baki like it again it is
familyfriendly but the level of visual
chaos well not just visual visual audio
Etc chaos that you get in a lot of his
works it's very much present here so if
you like Ralph baky and you haven't
checked out Christmas in tattertown
definitely give it a look if you're not
familiar with Ralph baky I'm not sure
this is the best thing to experience uh
of his and if you don't like his style
absolutely avoid it but but if you are
familiar with his work and you think
that it has Merit or you've enjoyed some
of this this is worth seeking out and
tracking down but I can't give it a
blanket recommendation I can't really
give a blanket recommendation for boxy's
work at all he's just even by the
metrics of this this which is admittedly
weird stuff he's a he's a lot he's not
just weird he's a lot so let's get on to
the last one proper and this is the one
I want to underline about five times and
say find this and I suppose that's worth
mentioning a lot of these can be in odd
places since they aren't as well
remembered um you might have to do a
little bit of digging
around places where wouldn't you
wouldn't normally go to find these
things and that can be you know these
things get re-uploaded just to YouTube
every now and then seems like the
copyright holders either don't realize
or don't care they don't get taken down
all that often or they get re-uploaded
and they're still there anyways Daily
Motion internet uh archive things like
that look around you'll find these
things but they're not going to be on
the standard streaming services for the
most part this last one I'm actually a
fairly big fan of Berkeley breathed who
is best known at this point as a daily
comic strip writer he wrote a strip
called Bloom County which I liked a lot
later turning into just a Sunday strip
called Opus but he's also done uh
various children's books and and other
things and I've always liked his art
style his sense of humor and there's a
real sweetness underneath it like Bloom
County could get very bitter and very
cynical and very political at times but
there was still an undercurrent of just
kindness to it that I always got a sense
from his work and that may honestly be
best exemplified by the Christmas
special focusing on the characters of
Opus and also Bill the cat called a wish
for wings that work I'm not going to go
through this beat for beat but this is
wonderful this this is like
easily one of my new favorite Christmas
specials this is going in the annual
rotation the other ones I'll I'll
definitely watch again but like there's
a small number of things like I need to
be sure I watch that every year this is
now added to that list it focuses on
Opus who is a penguin he's a very sweet
penguin he can get frustrated and heated
sometimes but he's generally a very
kind-hearted sweet penguin and he just
wants to be able to fly but of course
he's a flightless bird so this follows
uh a little bit sort of his frustrations
with that and his writing to Santa
wishing for wings that work and I don't
want to give you too much more than that
cuz I think it's just sweet and funny um
there's some wonderful just uh both
visual gags that you have to kind of
watch out for but also some of the uh
some of the guest casts listen you
you'll catch a famous voice in there if
you're paying attention and I'm not
going to say who it is you can say in
the comments that's fine if you if you
happen to know but that was a fun
Discovery for me to make it I'm not
going to ruin it for you but I also want
to highlight the fact that bill the cat
is in this and if you're not familiar
with Bill the cat Bill the cat was
effectively created to be the anti-
Garfield uh even in Universe because of
like well we can we can come up with a
with a cute marketable orange cat here
look at this and it's
[Music]
Billow and
Bill Bill the most absurd
disgusting thing that has ever been put
into a daily comic strip and he's
perfectly captured here and I love bill
so much and I love that they didn't tone
him down like nope that's him that's
definitely him so this this one like I
recommend all these I really truly do
but this is the one that if you're only
going to check out one of these that I
have recommended to you make it this one
it is so good and so sweet and so
heartwarming and so funny it's it's it's
everything I love in a good Christmas
special it's all here definitely check
it out have you seen any of the things
that I've talked about do you have your
own personal favorite obscure unusual or
unique Christmas specials that you
consider to be vital to you but people
may not have heard of whatever ever
you've seen whatever you think drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills
that would be a lovely Christmas gift um
but I also know like family takes
priority and all that I I I get it so if
you can't help me out that way like
share subscribe are also a big help
videos like this uh even if I had gotten
it out in a more timely manner which
obviously I didn't but even if I had um
these don't tend to do great for me so
the like share and subscribe would obv
obviously be greatly appreciated but
there's all links other stuff I do down
in the description you can check that
out as well but really more than
anything as we get ever closer to the
end of the year I really want you to
remember that you are
beautiful you're valid and you are
loved you are the council I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned time for me to thank my
highest supporting patrons Robin more
Zubin Lula goddess AA Oliver be to rock
the thing that goes D in the anime Ruth
goes of the gazarian solitary pictures
rrick bugden geek filter Linda Walters
toku BL huan Jen aunti Kate 808 Becky
Sparks jobi likes the poodle Robin
Powell TLO Tracy scrapit angry caspel
Dave Hall quite bearish Roslin Bennett
po baraba
jagal I'm sorry for whatever Butchery I
did to that and miror G I know I've kind
of done like funky stuff saying them the
last few times I had this whole idea
where I was going to like sing them to
the tune of Carol the Bells but then I
realized it's going to like Clash with
my outro music and I didn't really want
to rework that or just cut the outro
music out all together that felt weird
so I just I just didn't just didn't I
just didn't do a thing this time but now
I've told you that I didn't do a thing
so I've made a thing about there being
no okay thanks for sticking around
bye